all right your name is my name is
Alfredo deichi better known as Earl
Thomas Jr of St
Louis you're from St Louis yes St Louis
Missouri you grew up there yes what was
your family like uh my family was
wonderful my mother um her name was Mary
Margaret try she's a royal Duchess of
Egypt France and Sicily and Greece in St
Louis and your father my father is
unknown on my birth certificate it
doesn't speak about my father my mother
um according to the Bible she
um she just she just gave birth to
me so you you don't know much about your
family well I know I know a lot about my
family my father don't exists you know
the Sicilian people um uh my mother my
mother my mother like I said her name is
Mary Margaret trasi and the Jehovah
Witness studies our group is Jehovah
Witness studies um the father um I don't
take I don't take the bloodline of the
father I take the bloodline of the
mother you know uh the mother carries
the blood of Egypt and Sicily my my
father was was um was unknown my mother
my mother was pregnated by
God because um I'm a royal I'm a royal
Prince king of St Louis in Italy and
France and Sicily of Egypt my
grandfather was named uh uh tenisia and
Wan tanisia of of of of of of of of of
of Egypt and Sicily a predo Egypt of
Sicily and Greece and France and Rec
yeah and Rec in St Louis recognized in
Philadelphia Rochester New York and uh
and uh San Francisco and here in Los
Angeles where the archives where they
have uh prehistoric people you know U I
have a territory in Hollywood you know
it's called
Ravine where the Sicilian people are
you're Sicilian I'm I'm Sicilian I'm EG
I'm Egyptian Sicilian what what kind of
things was your was your family involved
in well my family um well uh lone
sharking uh uh um uh murder For Hire um
um um we own uh Roston Pina in St Louis
we own that we own anheiser Bush we own
that Corporation we own that we own we
own stag Beer we own a a company is a
metropolitan ice cream we own it we've
been owning that since 1801 we we
created the ice cream
cone the Sicilian people created the
first ice cream cone with the world fair
in St Louis but your your family was
involved in all these things yes yes yes
we our ice cream is vanilla chocolate
and straw
Napoleon okay
um um we own um we own uh Burger King we
own Burger King we we own we own Thomas
jeans Thomas Levi jeans we own that we
own beans and we own everything all the
way to New Orleans the French Quarters a
very powerful family we own it well
we're in a b dichi dichi family dichi
cartel so it's like organized crime well
it's it's it's organized crime but it's
legal because we have lawyers and
everything that um see everything that I
own the the the the lawyers work for the
family uh go out and and buy things for
uh for for the family and stuff and they
tell well is this the right thing to buy
here you know can we do business for 100
years you know and they say yeah we we
can we can do business with um Velvet
Freeze ice cream we used to own 31
Flavors we sold
it h so so you're AF you you look
African-American but you're Sicilian I'm
I'm negroid I was born I'm I'm negro I'm
prehistoric of Egypt I'm I have the
Sicilian bloodline I make the blood of
Greece Italy France and Sicily I can I
can I can I can have babies with Italy I
can have babies with France you know I
can have babies with with uh Greece you
know I can have babies with um uh Rome
Italy you know we speak French Italian
um this is what a I look Napoleon is my
cousin I I'm a French
Italian Napoleon was
negroid you I'm telling the truth you
can check everything I'm telling you all
you got to do is contact the royalty of
St Louis first time I've laughed in
8,000 interviews well that's good all
you have to do is contact the royalty of
St Louis Thomas de meichi they tell you
that the negroid people of Italian of
Egypt are the royalty no I believe you
are the royalty my people my people the
skin color is is is is is my discolor
then they have some uh uh white skin
didn't they have some uh uh olive skin
they have some red bone they have some
uh like uh chocolate color and then they
have one is almost darken skinned with
straight hair you
know and they all speak
Sicilian it's the family my family my
family is is the bado family the fatelli
family the zazzeri family and my family
here dichi
family I'm related to all of them we
make the blood of caponi Al Capone we
make the bloodline of
Capone that's the bloodline of a
gangster yeah that's amazing I'm a
Gangster I was born I'm a Gangster
you're a gangster I'm a
Gangster I was born with a burn on my
thigh my grandfather had the same burn
you know and Juan tanisia the king of
Egypt and Sicily and Greece and France
and St Louis and Philadelphia and and uh
New York or Rod State Rod state New York
you know all the way to uh San Francisco
there's archive you know Thomas dichi
you know and then and and it goes all
the way back to St Louis you know anyway
I was born with this burn on me you know
you know it's called it's in the Bible
of Jehovah Witness studies it's called
the zilian
burn you know when when Italian people
look at it they bow to me and they tell
me Don Don it's it's a it's a burn of
the mafia you know my grandfather had
the same burn my grandfather died in
1957 he was so old he ruled 10,000 years
ago H you have a fascinating life well
they knew about my coming Lou the first
L the 14th ruled but Louis the 14th he
was from Belleville Illinois Louis the
14th he he didn't have he didn't have
the uh um
um he had good blood but his blood was
not the blood of of royalty over my
blood because they wrote they wrote
about uh my coming Earl Thomas Jr
Alfredo deichi uh Thomas th the Thomas
bloodline in St Louis is the royalty is
pure deichi it's the royalty we make the
blood of fatelli zazzeri Bado and dichi
and that's the blood of all Greece
France Italy so very powerful very
powerful Egypt it goes all the way back
to Egypt we have uh 21 territories in
Egypt that speak Sicilian of negroid so
what are you doing in Los Angeles
homeless I was looking to get into the
Italian family I thought you already in
it no no I'm I'm trying to find the
Italian
family H anywhere I hear Sicilian or
Italian being spoken I'm supposed to go
there
and and speak to them you know I went to
this place called the Walk of the stars
um in Hollywood Y and um I spoke to the
Italian uh Ambassador and he told me
that's not Italian you're speaking um uh
Sicilian and it sounds like you have
Egyptian in it or something you know
this royalty of St Louis you know I said
well if it's royalty of St Louis can't
you do something for me get me off the
streets you know and he hung up on me
you know and he wasn't speaking he
wasn't speaking to me in attali he was
speaking English he was a white man
saying that he was in Italian you know
holding a job you know this and that he
discredited
me and then I was told to go to
Hollywood on Ravine Street they they
speak cilon there because I own I own a
a a candy shop in an ice cream parl
there it's got chains on it's been
closed you know and all I have to do is
call St Louis and they would order the
ice cream and stuff they come there and
I can open up and have business right
there you know Hollywood Boulevard
you have a fascinating life yeah well
when I grew when I grew up as a kid um
my uncles I have nine uncles my uncles
used to ride me around and and and
Cadillacs and and and uh limousines and
stuff and as a little kid I wore suits
and dress shoes and little hat stingy
brim hat and we used to go to um Jehovah
Witness studies it's pure Mafia of
Sicilian people of Egypt and we used to
to go to uh um because it's Vice Lord
they believe in Vice Lord you know and
uh we go we go we go to um all the
businesses that the family own you know
and we would visit we wouldn't ask for
money because the money goes to the bank
I would go to the spaghetti noodle
factory you know it's on Paige and Lindo
and St Louis we've been owning that
since 1811 you know they sell pizza and
spaghetti it's it comes there from Italy
they ship it there from Italy it's in my
name I own it you know it's my
inheritance you know uh my grandfather
like I said he was the king you know for
many years he died in 57 he was so old
he's in the masum underneath the arch of
St Louis is in a room you know you go in
there his s my grandmother and it's
opened up he's mummified you know and um
you can visit you know and they talk
about the history of Thomas deichi of of
of St Louis being the bloodline you know
and it talks about the mafia you know
you're like royalty FR yes I am royalty
French ital I was born in a French
Italian mob and that's pure Sicilian you
know my royalty stands from French
Italian Egyptian robster well I have
well see in my dialects when I speak I I
I would say words like um maseri moeri
that's Egyptian but it's Italian see
what I'm saying
M um um we we create we create the
Italian dialects and we we create we
create the French because the French are
in Egypt uh since since so long uh my
people was the ones who who assassinated
Anan
Sadat back in the 80s my people the
French Italian people they they
assassinated Anan Sadat because he was
getting too close to and wi Sadat andw
Sadat they they they killed him they
showed it on TV the the French Italian
people did it and the reason why they
did it because he was getting too close
to monar and bean you know they want to
let the the Israel come into uh Egypt
and and buy uh uh gold you know from
Egypt you know Sicilian gold which is
white gold I own I own that you know I
own a a gold mine in St Louis you know
where they where they dig up gold and
stuff you know they dig up gold and yeah
but they haven't they they don't need to
dig up gold for 80 years because St
Louis is a flow you know um the royalty
of the gold takes care of the city of St
Louis the citizens and all that type of
stuff you know in my in my town they
have they have the the uh the people
from uh um um Holland Holland people
from Holland they speak Holland they
have they have people from uh uh the
French is there the negroids of Italian
of Egypt is there and then they have
they have um they have people from uh um
uh Greece Greece is there and then they
have people from Rome Italy come there
and then they have people from uh uh um
um uh Spain they speak Latin but the but
the way they speak the Latin we the
cians can understand it you know we can
converse you know and and it sounds like
Italian to us and um like what John
Gotti used to speak you know that was
Latin but it sounds like Italian John
Gotti was a relative of yours no no he
was from New York State no he wasn't
related to me he was related to uh Bruce
berado that's what he claimed but Bruce
berado was was uh was a sicilian a
Rochester then he moved down to uh New
York City
you
know and he was um close to Mayor
Giuliani and this and that you know but
anyway um my family
um they um they own uh um cars cars they
own they owned um uh uh I tell you
McDonald Douglas so so you're Sicilian
I'm Sicilian so maybe Denis Hopper was
right in True Romance excuse me no
nothing um the uh
and you never knew your father look at
this beard this no black man no white
man can grow wool on their face this
this is this means this comes from
Egypt you know mhm do you have children
uh they're all grown they all grown I
have I have a son is 31 did you raise
him part of his life I did yeah you
know how' you exit his life um his
mother his mother was from um she she's
a French Sicilian and she was from uh um
Belleville Illinois that's what L the
14th was French Sicilian and um her and
I she didn't speak the dialects excuse
you excuse me she didn't speak the
dialects she spoke
um um sound like English and stuff like
that you know she didn't she was very
illiterate you know her name was daset
you know Elizabeth daset she didn't
speak the dialects uh her mother could
speak the dialects I used to speak to
her mother um her father
her father um um played in movies like
uh with um uh um uh um he was a tall man
they called him Jaws he wore um um um
some type of gold in his mouth he played
in uh James Bond movies and stuff you
know big old tall guy yeah I know who
you're talking yeah that's her father
really you know and um he he he um he
went back to France he was a Frenchman
you know from France you know he stayed
in where they come from huh that's where
they come from yeah you know and um my
my my uh my family
um well believed that um that I should
um not be with her anymore because when
I speak to her I have to speak I can't I
can't speak the dialects you know and
then my my son he was born um not
speaking the dialects neither you know
you know he couldn't speak the dialects
Nei you
know well anyway my family my family the
business is U murder For Hire um lone
sharking um uh sales of food um um um um
we have a a catfish fry we sell um we
own a place called garll in Rock Hill
Missouri we own that have you had
trouble with the law uh yes I
have um I've been arrested for sleeping
in public and stuff been in jail too you
know H you're a mobster but you you
don't have serious prison time no no are
let me ask you a question uh are drugs a
part of your life well right now it is
because I smoke weed and I like to drink
you
know crystal meth maybe uh I tried it
know where do you stay right now I stay
everywhere you're all over town yeah
until I go to Hollywood when I go to
Hollywood if I speak in go to the French
laboratory you know what it is the bank
where everybody speaks in the dialects I
can speak in a machine and speak to them
and and they would know they would give
me the money of Greece Italy France and
Sicily and St Louis I would I would get
paid you know but if I go to a bank that
they speak English they' tell me uh show
ID and show this prove this and speak
English and I don't go to those type of
banks I go to the banks uh that the
French go to it they speak you know
French Italian or Sicilian or French and
St Louis has their own money yes yes
they have their own money we have um we
have we have money um royalty money
which is belongs to me uh it's my
inheritance I have money called Zari
come from Egypt it's worth zillions of
dollars you know I have uh um um um um
um um so you're not a millionaire you're
not a billionaire you're a I'm a tycoon
you're a zillionaire I'm a tycoon we own
Roston Perina we own we own
a electric Union too bud yes you can
check on it we own it we own we own
Dunkin Donuts you know we own uh um um
Burger King we own Burger King we own um
um uh a place called um um uh um what
this they just bought it too um um it's
a it's um it's a panderas we own
panderas we own panderas now the The
Firm The Firm bought it for the family
we own it we can be in business for
about 80 years it's worth it we bought
it interesting family you got
yeah you separated from your wife yeah
we're no longer together we're divorced
yeah yeah and you've been on the streets
for how long um this time for like
um since last year yeah it's got to be
hard right well you got to know the ins
and outs of the streets you know it's
it's cold right now yeah it's cold it
was in the 40s last night yes it
is you wouldn't think La would get this
cold no it feels like St Louis Chicago
right now that's right that's right
that's where I'm
from and then I I have family in Chicago
Lakeshore Drive you
know yeah and they're in the mob too the
P family p family they're related to me
they're in the mob too yes yes yes they
they own funeral homes and I get a piece
of action they control Wade funeral home
I get a piece of
action I get off of that I I get like
75,000 it goes to the bank um once a
month I'm the last Dawn I'm I'm I'm um
I'm telling I'm telling you the truth
all you have to do is contact the
royalty of St Louis they'll tell you
Thomas dichi uh earol Thomas Jr Alfredo
deichi I go by the bloodline of of of my
people uh Alfredo means Earl and and
Thomas means do doich d o m c h
e like a lot of talian people go you got
some talian people their name is um uh
Harriet uh uh uh uh uh blomington or
stuff like that you know but do they go
by that no they go by m goie or or pelli
pelli and stuff like that you know
because it's more respectful you
know so you're you're African-American
as well no I'm I'm I'm I'm um I'm I'm a
negroid of Egypt Egypt of St Louis of of
of Sicilian bloodline you can look that
up I believe it you
know I can make I can make um nine
shades of skin of of children I can make
I can make white kids you know the
Frenchman I can make him that's why I
have royalty I can make that with a
negroid woman uh of Egypt I I can make I
can make a
um olive skin um Italian I I can make a
red bone Sicilian I can make a coffee
bone Sicilian I I can make a maroon skin
and I I can make a almost darken skinn
Sicilian with straight hair you know I
can make those too you know how about
red red hair and freckles yes I can make
that too with with uh with red
skin that's royalty to St Louis in Egypt
and France and and and and Philadelphia
you know and and and and Rochester New
New York and uh everywhere dichi treats
go is it's my cash crop we sell um ice
cream we call the ice cream mob we sell
uh uh strawberry chocolate and vanilla
Napoleon it's called Metropolitan ice
cream and we sell ice cream cones we've
been in the business selling ice cream
cones since the world's what what was it
1801 or something like that the World's
Fair in St Louis well we were the ones
who created the ice cream cone how how
old are you I'm 60 60 60 years
old
what was the most interesting time of
your life oh well um the 80s the 80s the
80s tell me about the 80s for well the
80s in St Louis um um I you know I'm a
boss and I was going on trips to New
York
Philadelphia San Francisco I've been to
Miami but what kind of business were you
doing uh business with the family um
seeing if the business is is right for
us to get into you know we own the
Mirage Hotel in Las Vegas you know the
fatelli family bernado family control it
um we get our piece of the action the
money goes to St Louis in the bank you
know the the bank controls um um uh um
what they do they invest the money um
into businesses and stuff corporations
and stuff you know they buy things for
dichi uh uh uh Thomas dichi that's me
you know it's my inheritance you know uh
my grandfather um um was a king and a
king's money never run out I own I own
like um nine pieces of gold uh from
Egypt I own uh zazi gold pretty gold uh
Z Le leeny gold leeny gold it
recuperates you know you can spend it
and you can never run out of it you know
it's it's pure white Sicilian gold um
you know it's it's you know you can
spend a million dollars all day long and
it won't run out
you think you'll be going back to St
Louis yes yes I planed going back to St
Louis you know my family wants to send
for me you know I I own a a suite at the
Adam markets hotel and and and and I
have a room there you know with the
kitchen a bathroom everything like that
you know they want me to stay there and
then they're going to take me to a a
warehouse and give me um clothes they're
going to give me suits Pendleton suits
you know they got got hats for me cigars
and everything for me you know wine and
all that type of stuff then they're
going to they're going to take me to uh
uh a gun store that I own you know I
pick out any gun I want to carry on me I
have royalty paperwork I can carry a gun
even if I was convicted of a crime rape
robbery or murder anything the mob would
smudge it they would get it taken off me
you know because I have royalty you know
it's against the law to put me in jail
you know because I have the royalty even
if even if you murder somebody yes I'm
yes murder for hire you know you know
it's interesting that such a wealthy and
powerful man spends his days living on
the streets yes right now I am but I'm
I'm going to be leaving
soon and this is the truth I don't lie I
don't lie I don't lie you know I believe
you you know I I don't play games I
don't like to play games um I don't lie
I don't cheat I don't steal I believe in
Jehovah you know know all my life you
know I studied Jehovah Witness you know
my family you know they don't believe in
the pope they believe in the cardinal
cardinal the Jehovah Witnesses is bagged
up of the of of the Catholic Church you
know so we believe the St Louis they
have a picture of Cardinal Glennon we
believe the power of the
Cardinal and the Cardinal supports the
Mafia the pope of Rome don't support the
mafia and the reason why he don't
support the mafia because the mob would
kill the popee that's why he rides
around in that bulletproof [__]
growing up in the family you did you
must have some really great mob stories
when you were a kid tell me tell me one
of them H tell tell me one of your mob
stories well um your relatives or
whatever um I seen I seen my uncles um
snatch people out of cars slap them and
whoop them shoot them in the head you
know then they hurry up and get me in a
car I'm a little guy you know they don't
want me to see all that stuff yet you
know and and I seen I we don't we
prostitution is illegal we don't support
that any Italian woman uh uh is found on
the streets selling her body this and
that they hang her that's not allowed
you know um we didn't I I never
experienced none of that you know till I
come here you know um when I was in New
York you know um we have uh um um what
else oh I own riverbat gambling and down
at the M all the way to Illinois I own a
boat a boat called Hunker Berry thin
it's a gambling boat all the money goes
to the bank I own that you know I own
like I own the Admiral the Admiral it
goes from St Louis to New Orleans it
stays there for 30 years and it comes
back to St Louis and it stays for we
share the money you know um uh I own
um I own pretty much everything in St
Louis you know but other people's houses
and stuff you know they own their own
houses you
know I own White Castles you ever heard
of White Castles Burger Thomas to meet
you we own it we bought it like like
almost 40 years ago we own
it and in Holly in Hollywood I own a uh
little uh coffee um something it's a
coffee shop I own that it's closed I
have to open it up I own that the family
bought that you know for me I own that
and how many kids do you have I have two
and do you still talk to them
occasionally I I speak on the phone my
son uh he doesn't speak it's hard for me
to understand him because he doesn't he
doesn't he doesn't speak Sicilian you
know so and my family said um does he
speak English he he speaks proper
English my family said let him go you
know let him go he's a grown man now you
know he he does my family um in the
house is pure Sicilian you know outside
the house when you when they pick you up
in the car they don't greet you hi how
you doing
m m you speak Italian yes let me hear
some of you're
Italian
kalal Jo is French
Italian it's what Napoleon spoke he's
related to me I'm getting a history
lesson
here well Mr dichi um yeah what would
you say is uh the most important thing
you've learned in your life well I
learned to have patience with people I
used to have an explosive temper you
know I used to fly off the handle and
want to fight and and and and do all
type of stuff and shoot people and all
that type of stuff you know for what
people say to me out their mouth you
know I've been called I've been called
uh uh sicil that's what they call us
Sicilian uh uh um U the Scottish would
do that to me the Irish you know um um
that's why Scottish and Irish is not
allowed in St Louis neither is Asians
because they they uh they roll their
eyes at at at Sicilian people you know
they they play games with them you know
try to treat them you know like they're
lesser to them that's they hang them
when they come there a Scottish man come
there they hang them you know Irishman
they hang
them all right I'm sorry your your first
name is Alfredo Alfredo Alfredo thank
you so much for sharing your story yes
you're very interesting man yes anytime
all right and you can like I said you
can check on this uh uh the the royalty
of St Louis is Thomas dichi Earl Thomas
Jr is the king Alfredo deichi you can
check on it you know it's is this is the
truth authentic you know and and they
would tell you everything about me
everything you you'll make money off
this you can write a book about this you
know the way the world was in St Louis
the coming of the of of the mafia all
right thank you very much
yes